after to John Dorian temple for full
more way please I've Table five yes he'd
never met some guys hey Jessie Colin's
gone for a simple dish so he's cooking
must rely on flavors not frills and I'm
not sure he's nailed it
before he passed that it takes it in
fragrant like a like bouillabaisse but
it's almost like it's lost his fishiness
it's done with more veggies you want it
to taste or what's on that off fish
exactly Frank today they have to make
sure that dish is all about flavor not
how things look stark how long please
ten seconds speech there second yeah
work together come on guys Joey check
your plates
nice wait we're together work together
one's gonna yeah fiber colors love the
idea of the egg yolk on there let's go
good probably those Colleen Lisa yeah
they look fantastic
go Table one please go beautiful I love
that level of creativity and the
confidence to be that simple without red
mullet brilliant last night we asked
make it to look absolutely perfect like
the first hello yes okay great channel 3
please let's go so thank you very much
for this lab it probably get over every
one of your dishes yes okay
pan-fried red mullet tomato fondue
courgettes finished with potato galette
on top collins presentation is brilliant
and i don't expect nothing less
but i hope his dish is as successful as
leggings service is over and it's time
to find out which of these two
incredible dishes
my guests preferred starting with
Winningham fields let's talk fish
summertime and yeah it's really simple
and the skin was really nice and crispy
and it was still very fresh and from the
pan it was like being in the
Mediterranean on a sunny day sunshine
I'm gonna play John Dory was it I think
it was very nice but the whole balance
of the dish was beautiful
we all found I think that the oyster was
a slightly odd thing because we couldn't
quite tell what it was yeah interesting
Charlie dory I loved the love the fish
and really delighted by the oyster I
thought that was a real treat both
French teams have excelled themselves in
my kitchen serving up exquisite food
worthy of their reputations and mine
think to go through the semi-finals
would be it would be excellent for the
restaurant for everyone back in
Edinburgh all the staff we've worked
that I think of it be a a dream come
true for us all
we're team of the printer for thinking
and then we take it from there I was
happy with everything we went out there
was nothing I wasn't happy with each
individual part was cooked I wanted to
be cooked so everything went out I'm
happy now I must decide which team has
that all-important virginity quark to
take them through to the semi-final